[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to the webcast on api innovation
with a consumer mindset
first things first just wanted to thank
everyone kind of taking time out of your
day to kind of join me
uh to talk about this topic so just to
kind of kick things off a brief
introduction to myself uh my name is
warren choi i'm a global digital advisor
with apogee
more specifically i work with our
customer success team so
been with apogee for oh god almost seven
years now
during that entire time really working a
lot with our our customers uh kind of
getting api programs
started from the ground up and really
working with you know c-level executives
vps directors on business strategy and
even just you know from a delivery
aspect
of getting api programs kind of started
from scratch and so
this topic in particular is something
that is near and dear to my heart
super happy to kind of spend some time
to talk about it with you guys today
all right in terms of topics that kind
of what we wanted to cover uh you might
have seen this in the agenda as well
as part of the description for this
webcast but we really wanted to go over
different aspects of what it means when
it comes to
a user or a consumer-centric approach
to api design and api innovation so more
specifically we wanted to kind of
revisit the digital value chain
this might be something that you might
be familiar with so i promise i will
only spend
just a few minutes kind of revisiting
what the digital value chain is
and more specifically what it means in
terms of the api consumer
we're going to be talking about the
outside in approach and why it's better
dive a little bit into developer
engagement best practices to promote
api adoption examples of what we see in
the industry so this is kind of
pertaining what i was mentioning before
of of the experience that we've had
working with the various customers over
the years
of kind of how they've approached it and
and some common trends that we've seen
and also just how to get started from
your perspective
you know if you kind of want to go down
this journey you know what are some of
the questions and things to consider
that you need to think of as you kind of
move into this approach
and then last but not least we'll spend
a little bit of time covering
any questions that you guys may have and
uh to the best of my ability i will
i will answer them so to get started and
i mentioned this uh
you know when we're talking about the
topics as well so the digital value
chain is something that apogee has been
pitching for
pretty much my entire time that i've
been here with uh with the company
uh it is sort of the bread and butter
way of how we explain
you know the api journey or or how apis
relate to
the end-to-end kind of life cycle or all
the different systems that are kind of
involved when it comes to apis
so if you haven't if you've seen this
before uh you know i apologize in
advance i'm gonna go over it just really
really quickly but if you haven't
i will give you kind of a brief overview
because this is really the
foundation of the subsequent
conversations we'll be having
specifically around you know this whole
concept of a api consumer-centric
approach to two apis
so i'm gonna be starting over from the
left and slowly moving over to the right
um so at the leftmost bit you have your
consumer so this is
this is the end user right these are the
people using
the applications that are going to be
power uh that are powered by your apis
so a good way of thinking about this if
you look at it from like mobile apps
perspective this is you and me these are
people with
you know our our iphones or our pixel
phones
we're using applications uh or mobile
applications and those applications are
essentially powered by api so
that's us that customer here is
referring to the end user
when it comes to apps and experiences
that's what i was just mentioning before
that is the application itself that is
the
thing on your phone where you know you
go in and uh if you want to
you know um you know use payment bank
payments
uh the weather app the news app you know
whatever it is
that is the application that we use and
that application is powered by
um by apis now who develops those apis
is the developer which is the third
item that you see here on this list that
application was built for by a developer
and that developer powers their
application
based off of apis or in this case it's
called the api product which will get a
little bit
into more details uh later on in this
webcast
and that's really when we talk about api
that's kind of
the the core aspect that we're talking
about from that perspective
those apis are built by an api team now
now we're getting a little bit into
you know you the developers potentially
in your organization right if you have
an api program these are the people
building the apis
for those developers to build the apps
for the end consumer so you're kind of
you know starting to see
what we mean here when we say the
digital value chain right they're all
kind of connected and all kind of
related
in that sense and then of course you
know apis themselves
you know they got to get the data from
somewhere right and so that's where
you know we we considered this the the
back end so this could be things like
databases or your backend services you
know things that
you may want to expose out to the
developers or having
that data that capability expose that to
your developer but
packaged up in an api so
you know just to kind of reiterate
customer and user
end user uses the application like in
this case for my example like a mobile
application
those applications are built by the
developer
those developers are using apis in this
case this is when it starts to come into
kind of
you know your realm start using your
apis to power the applications that
they're building
those apis are built for by an api team
and then those apis and the api team
really are building apis around some
sort of backend system or backend
service that you may have in place
already
so the topic of this webcast we're
really going to be focusing on
what we call the the consumer of the
apis
so you may have guessed it already when
we're talking about the consumer we're
really talking about
the developer level that you kind of see
here
now when we talk about api consumer that
can be you know you can kind of break
that up into different subcategories
right
in the context of developers they could
be
external developers so this could be a
person working out of their garage
and and they're building some you know
revolutionary new application
they have nothing really to do with your
organization they're not even really
considered a partner of your
organization
but they may actually use your apis if
your apis are open to the public
to build some sort of functionality for
some application that they want to roll
out
to the end user these can also be
partner developers so people that are
external to your organization but maybe
like a partner company
that you may work with to build some
sort of uh application that you know a
joint
application that you guys want to roll
out to provide some value to your
customers
they can also even be internal
developers and they're not really listed
here on the
sheet but i mean even internally the way
that you can also look at it as well
is that you know you may have an api
programmer and or a team that builds
apis
but your consumer is another part of
your organization building some sort of
internal application to roll out to
rather internally or even externally to
your to your end consumers as well
so as you can see here you know when we
talk about the api consumer
um you know we really are talking about
the
the consumers of the api but those
consumers can be
you know different people both within
and outside of your your organization
so when we talk about this whole concept
of a uh consumer approach
uh these are kind of things where uh you
gotta wanna ask yourself you know
if you have an api program established
already you know have you
heard of any of this feedback before
right things like
you know the api documentation isn't
documented very well
or i'm having trouble finding the apis
that are pertaining to the application i
want to build
or the apis just doesn't do what i
wanted to right or
you know i just cannot figure out how an
api works
when we come when we talk about
user-centric approach to api design and
api innovation this is really
what we want to focus on right we want
to start addressing
the fact that what we see as
api programs that are successful really
do take a
consumer-centric or user-centric
approach
to how they design how they implement
how they roll out their apis
so if you're hearing a lot of these kind
of feedback
uh within your own api program then this
webcast kind of is you're kind of
the target audience of who we want to
talk to uh specifically in in the
topics that we're going to be covering
later on so one of the reasons or
how we kind of explain you know why you
may be getting the feedback that that we
just talked about
is uh this whole concept of inside out
and outside in approach
to apis so once again i'm gonna revisit
the digital value chain in this case
so when we talk about inside out this is
when we start talking about think of it
in terms of how you design an api
traditionally if you kind of look at you
know the what i call that kind of the
old school model
of api design when you start talking
about api design from a legacy
perspective a lot of times what we see
is that a lot of our customers start off
with a
inside out approach and so what i mean
by that is they have some back-end
service or some data they think is going
to be useful and and really when they
start building apis
they're not really taking the customer
or the
app developer uh in this case you know
the the external consumer into account
they're really just
saying i have all this data i have all
this goodness in terms of backend
services
how do i just wrap that into an api and
then just sort of
roll that out there for the masses to
consume
right uh it's sort of this whole like
you know build it and they will come
kind of approach to to api design
uh and what we see happen is they really
just kind of
repackage what the back end service it
uh provides
and just kind of throw it out there now
the problem with this is that
a lot of times you know the back-end
services are
complex they're not necessarily
straightforward or self-uh
explanatory when it comes to
understanding what it does
um even from a data perspective and so
if i'm
a if i'm a person within the
organization it may make perfect sense
but if i'm that guy who's building the
application in my garage and i i have no
idea how your backing services work
you can kind of see a scenario here
where that becomes a little bit of an
issue
right um if i'm just getting an api
that's sort of like a data dump of
of uh all these different fields and and
data
i may have a hard time understanding you
know what exactly
i need to extract to get my needs as an
app developer out of that
and so that's sort of this whole inside
out concept right
now what we promote is sort of the
opposite of that this is the outside in
approach
if you guys are familiar with this whole
thing of api first
method of api design um then this is
sort of kind of related to that and and
really what we mean by that
is when you're designing your apis or
you're kind of approaching your api
program you kind of want to think of it
from
the the other way around right the
opposite of inside out which is you know
outside in
obviously and what we mean by that is is
you really want to start
thinking and putting yourself in the
shoes of the end user and the
uh application developer so a simple way
of thinking about it was
you know put yourself in the shoes of of
the application developer
if i was the person building the app
what sort of apis would i want to
uh consume right uh you know if i were
to
want the most easy self-explanatory
uh api to consume what would that look
like and really kind of
taking that mindset of saying what are
the needs of the end user what kind of
applications and data are they looking
for
and also what did the application
developers want in terms of
how to consume those apis and that
may or may not correlate to the back end
so i think this is where
you know it gets a little bit tricky
because a lot of times
especially if you're internal within
your organization and you have a good
understanding of what the backend
services provide
you tend to kind of want to go for
building out apis
that you know the backend service can
accommodate you know once again i
mentioned api first
where it becomes a little bit difficult
for for some of these teams and some of
these programs is that they have a hard
time
decoupling from that model and so they
may approach outside in with best
intentions but they always kind of get
into a position where it's really
just sort of a slightly better version
of the inside out model
what we want to promote is really just
kind of starting from a
blank slate and and using that as the
starting point right i mean to some
extent just forgetting
all about your backend servers and
saying purely from an application
perspective what are some cool apps what
are some cool functionalities that we
think will be needed
and then using that as the jumping off
point for for your api design
so once again to emphasize that i was
talking about before your api consumers
are important
right uh and and some of the things to
consider here is you really want to know
who your app developers are
and the applications that they're
building i already talked inside
out or and outside into death but you
know once again correlating with this
whole api first mentality api first
approach to api design
easy to consume apis i'm going to
mention this a little bit later in the
webcast but things about like really
taking a hard look at your apis and are
they
really easy to understand if i were to
just kind of go in and look at those
apis is it self-explanatory enough
do the field names make sense on their
own right do i need to
read some sort of long you know uh api
description document just to understand
what
what you know uh payload i'm receiving
when i'm making a call
and vice versa you want to make the
onboarding process simple and
frictionless this is something when i
talk about developer portal later on i'm
gonna uh i'll cover in greater detail
but you want to make sure that getting
access to your apis is is going to be a
very smooth and not a very convoluted
process
and then finally i mean build your
requirements to your
your consumers right not based off of
your own requirements right
really this is kind of putting once
again putting yourself in the shoes
of you know the app developer and the
end user and building requirements
from that perspective rather than just
you know these are uh
what services we have what are the
requirements of just you know packaging
it up and getting it out there
so we're going to touch a little bit
upon uh developer engagement this is all
sort of related to this this ongoing uh
you know stressing the importance of you
know the api consumer approach
so of course the developer engagement is
key to the success
of your api program uh what does that
require so
these are the kind of the three main
pillars that we see often in the
industry and this is something that we
promote heavily uh with our customers
first of all is this concept of api
products now i'm not going to go into
great detail of what an api product is
there's a lot of
documentation and videos and it's kind
of one of the core
foundations of apogee as a product is
the ability of bundling up your apis
into products but
very high level 10 000 foot description
of 8 what api products are is they're
essentially a bundle of apis
one way you can look at it i like to use
sort of the lego analogy right
if you guys are building out legos very
rarely do you go and buy lego pieces one
by one when you're creating something
more often than not you go into a store
and you buy a set
and that set comes with all the pieces
you need to build
whatever you know plane or boat or
whatever you want to build
so you can think of api products as that
set right it is a bundle of apis in this
case will be the individual lego pieces
but at the end of the day it's a bundle
of apis to
have some sort of you know core
functionality that you are providing to
to your application developers and your
consumers so having
a great api product methodology uh
and and rollout model is uh is key here
the other bit is a developer portal
having some sort of mechanism of
communicating out
apis allowing the developers to have a
place to go
and register to get access to your api
as well as you know getting
documentation and all those kind of
uh you know cool things through a some
sort of a easy to use self-explanatory
portal
is another trend we see as being very
important and then
also you know when it comes to developer
uh enablement right providing them with
the need
resources that they need and the support
that they need to be successful in
utilizing
your apis so when it comes to best
practices to promote adoption
uh we kind of have these four main
categories i'm going to deep dive into
each one of these
in just a little bit but those are
acquisition
documentation and onboarding
self-service and of course the support
and ongoing maintenance
of your of your api consumers so when we
talk about acquisition
these are kind of the things that we
talk about right this is sort of how do
we get your
app developers kind of onboarded and how
do we get them you know using your apis
and getting
excited to use your apis so the first
one is this thing a concept you may have
heard about it's called the 555
rule long story short within the first
five seconds you kind of want to grab
their attention
in the next five seconds you want to
build interest and then in the next five
minutes being able
uh and empowering them to build uh an
actual
case you know of using your apis
so once again this is really kind of
emphasizing
getting them excited about your apis and
getting them able to quickly
you know understand your api programs
what is it trying to accomplish and
really kind of building out
a use case for those apis in a very very
short amount of time
that relates to kind of some of the
other bullet points you see here such as
value proposition
the ability to how do you showcase your
apis right how do you kind of go out and
promote these apis and say hey
this is something you guys want to use
when you're building out your
applications
once again the api market is very very
competitive if you kind of really think
about it
uh there are a lot of different apis out
there
you know potentially you may have
competitors that have their own api
programs and
if you're really trying to win over
an external application developer for
example
having the most uh you know simple to
use
robust api catalog is really one way
you're going to win them over
right if i was a once again i'm keep
going back to this example of
the app developer that's working out of
the garage
you know if they're building out the
next revolutionary app
and they're using your api but they have
a a lot of different choices amongst you
and your competitors of which apis they
want to utilize to get the data that
they need
of course they're going to be leaning
more towards the apis that are
easier to consume rather than ones that
are more complicated and a little bit
more confusing right i mean they're
they're all about
rolling applications out very quickly
and and you really want to kind of
appeal to that that aspect of it
uh which kind of goes into that fourth
bullet point here about making uh
you know easy to get started making it
frictionless uh and then the la
the last one is really just um you know
something that we've seen a lot as well
you know
promoting hackathons uh you know this is
something that you know we as google we
do a lot
you know as you may have heard but you
know really just having different
mechanisms of really getting people to
kind of have hands-on experiences with
the apis
in order to acquire them as as uh
consumers for those apis
these are kind of uh kind of the key
tenants that we talk about the next one
is documentation and onboarding this
we're getting a little bit into
developer portal now
but really what we're talking about here
first off you know
how do we engage developers before
registration uh
this touches a little bit upon the
concept of you know a lot of times when
it gets access to apis they're kind of
locked behind this whole registration
wall
where if i want to even look into the
apis that are available within
a person's organization i need to kind
of go through this whole
five to ten step process of getting some
you know registered getting an api key
just to get access to play around with
it
um and we want to however it makes sense
you know given your business case
kind of eliminate that model right you
want to start
promoting these apis out there to the
public so that you know they can get a
good understanding of the value that or
the services that you're providing
without kind of jumping through hoops to
kind of getting access
doesn't mean necessarily that your you
know you're opening up access to all
your apis to just anyone in the public
once again this really does depend on
your your business case and kind of what
services you're providing
but the more you can get into this model
of kind of providing
open documentation or descriptions of
what services you can provide
the easier it's going to be and the
faster it's going to be for those uh
app developers to to really want to
start onboarding with with your api
program
when they do eventually register you
want to make sure that registration
process is
frictionless as well so this really kind
of goes into the whole concept once
again of
you know thinking of when it comes to
you know we were talking about api
design in the concept
of api first or from the from the
perspective of an application developer
this is the same thing just from a
registration point of view
right your registration process should
be thought of of if
i was an application developer what sort
of registration process would i want to
go through i guarantee you
that everyone wants a simpler
registration process
rather than a very complicated one that
takes you know
a week to get an api key you know they
want something quick
they want something fast and they want
something that that's very
straightforward and easy to to onboard
with uh self-service
uh so once again i touched a little bit
upon this when i was describing about
you know api design
early on um but you wanna make sure your
apis are are easy to understand
we talk a little about api products here
as well you know you want to make sure
that you know
you are when it comes to creating an
application or
having them playing around with your
apis you want it to be as
self-explanatory as you can possibly be
and what i mean and that goes you know
that can be looked at from a variety of
different ways right you can look at it
from
how these api uh request and response
payloads look like
you know how simple are they or or how
big the payloads are
um how granular the apis are for example
that's another way of doing it
but really it's the concept of like if
i'm building my initial application and
i just wanted to
quickly play around with your apis you
know what's the quickest most effective
way of doing that
and self-service self-explanatory kind
of apis is definitely the model we
recommend is
definitely the way to go and the api
programs that we see our customers have
the most success
those apis are very easy to understand
just kind of reading a
one to two sentence description or even
to some extent the api name itself
just reading it will if they can read it
and get a good understanding of oh i
know what this api does
then um you know the easier the better
uh and then there's also this whole
concept of you know having them try this
out this ties
once again with the whole registration
process but also
within the capability of apogee as a
product of
being able to call apis or doing test
calls through the portal itself
is something that you know we see a lot
of success with so if you can implement
something like that and provide them
with
some sort of you know try it now feature
within your developer portal
uh that is kind of the ideal method that
we recommend when it comes to the ease
of onboarding and the time to get
folks on board onto your api program uh
and last but not least support
maintenance uh this is sort of the
ongoing support
once they are kind of building
applications using your apis
what resources do they have in case they
run into roadblocks right
um what kind of documentation you know
what kind of
guides do they need to follow what sort
of write-up uh you know community
we talk about this whole concept of you
know you building out an api community
where you may have something like a
forum or a blog
or some sort of mechanism where they can
go in and ask
questions about like hey i'm running
into this issue with consuming an api
how do i get around it or i'm getting a
weird response can someone please
explain to me what this response is
and really you know it's once again it's
kind of providing them with the
resources that they need to be
successful
in using and consuming your apis and and
you know this could be within your
developer portal as well it could be
you know part of uh maybe dedicated role
that you have like an api evangelist or
some sort of product owner
but the other way of looking at this too
is really just having a mechanism of
capturing feedback
right you know once your apis are rolled
out it doesn't mean those apis will
forever not be changed right we have
versioning we want you to build out your
apis in iterations and constantly get
feedback from your api
consumers and app developers so that you
can further
iterate and enhance those apis to cater
to the needs of
where your business is going and
specifically who's consuming
those apis so here are some examples
that we've seen uh in the industry
i personally have seen a lot of this
with with a lot of our customer kind of
over the years
uh when they're talking about you know
taking this whole outside in approach
you know ease of use ease of onboarding
these are some common trends
i'm not going to go into the details of
kind of each one of these mean because
that's going to be
different webcasts and different topics
all in on its own
but i do recommend that if any one of
these are of interest to you definitely
kind of hit up either our apogee
community
or apogee docs page
this we have a lot of good documentation
on our website
that really deeps dive into a lot of
these different things whether they be
kind of industry standards and industry
trends
uh or very specific product capabilities
that
can kind of kind of help you out with
this so one of the one of the trends
that we see
is you know moving to restful apis right
a lot of our
customers specifically those with api
programs that have been around for a
while
they usually come from a kind of a soap
based you know api model those with you
know
things like xml payloads for example and
having that move
over to something more restful something
you know using json as you know from a
payload perspective
uh that's sort of you know one of the
common first steps we see
where you know just making the payload
easier to read right easier to use from
a
from a consumer perspective kind of with
that as well what we see a lot
when it comes to restful apis and kind
of you know specifically in the concept
of payloads
is a lot of times when we see with with
uh legacy apis that sometimes these
payloads are huge
they're giving them basically like all
the data within a specific call and just
to kind of comb through all of that to
get
specific maybe a specific feel that the
app developer needs
is sort of a kind of a tedious thing uh
you know using something like the apogee
api
you know platform to to customize
or to adjust the payload you know based
on maybe some sort of
uh you know entry criteria or some sort
of uh data that they're passing as part
of the api request
you know it's things that they can use
to kind of really either maybe shorten
or
you know filter out you know certain
fields uh pertaining to what the app
developer wants to use so there's a lot
of different ways that you can approach
it
but just keep in mind that you know once
again this whole concept of
you want your apis that are
self-explanatory but also easy to
consume
easy to read and easy to understand i
talked about
incorporating methods of feedback once
again blogs forums uh you know having a
dedicated role to kind of
go in and you know ping your application
developers and saying hey you know
what's working what's not
that is another way of really allowing
you to
better steer your api program in the
direction of
consumability and and you know having
this this whole
consumer kind of approach to apis so
that when you're investing your time and
resources of building that next version
of the api
you don't want to kind of just shoot in
the dark you really want to base it off
some hard data
some hard feedback both positive and
negative that you're getting from the
people actually using your apis
uh we talked about developer portal uh
you know already but once again
utilizing it in a very effective manner
you know when it comes to the
registration process when it comes to
documentation when it comes to this
whole try it now feature with apis
things like that
this one's an interesting one the whole
role of an api evangelist
a lot of times we don't see this role
when especially with our newer customers
right this is this is sort of a new role
that uh only you know kind of a select
handful of our customers
kind of have pre-established before you
know using
really rethinking their api program and
what we mean about api evangelists is
sort of like the person who promotes the
api
so this could be you know someone who
goes out and maybe hosts the hackathons
or really reaches out to your
application community and saying hey
look these are all the cool new apis are
being developed this is why
you want to use these apis and really
someone to kind of promote those apis is
um
is is kind of the purpose of this role
and a lot of times
this role is also combined with the
person who's the direct person getting
the feedback
you know when we talk about the feedback
the second bullet point here that's
that's also kind of related to that role
as well
simplifying the api registration process
once again we talked about that already
but you want it to be as simple as
possible you don't want it to be
a one-week two-week process of running
through manual approvals and sending
emails just to get an api key
if you can make this self-service to a
thing like a developer portal
make it you know within seconds to get
an api key rather than
uh you know a very manual process that
takes time
uh the faster the better and the easier
the better
and then once again this move to api
products once again it just kind of
makes
understanding the apis uh easier if you
were to kind of take a whole product
or a productization or a product centric
approach to it because once again you
know going back to the lego analogy
it's a little bit easier to understand
when it's sort of bundled in the context
of a specific
functionality or you know a specific
group um so that you know people can say
oh yeah that's the
api product i want to use because that
is the one closest
tied to the application i want to build
all right so let's say
uh you know you want to start getting
started let's say that you know
kind of going all the way back to one of
the earlier slides you are getting a lot
of this feedback that you know your api
program
has apis that are hard to use or just
people just having a hard time
understanding
you know how your apis work or it's a
very you know high touch kind of model
where
you need to constantly work your app
developers just to kind of get them on
board and
have them start consuming your apis and
understanding your apis
these are the common questions that you
know we ask our customers
and you would probably want to start
asking yourself and really kind of
taking a hard look at your api program
and really kind of saying okay
how do we start down this path of
getting to that model
that we want to get to this whole
outside in model
one is identifying you know who are who
are my api consumers and what
applications are they're building once
again this is really
having a good understanding of who's
actually consuming your apis
is definitely the first start if you
have no idea who's using your apis
that is a problem uh and so you want to
start addressing uh really understanding
who's consuming your apis how they're
consuming it uh and
you know what kind of you know feedback
that they have
the the other one is you know how
self-explanatory are the apis how easy
are they understand we talked about
whole restful earlier on as well right
when it comes to payloads when it comes
to api naming conventions
uh is it straightforward enough if i
hadn't had no idea what the backend
systems did
would i still be able to kind of piece
together what an api could do
based specifically just on the name
alone things like that
uh do i have a developer portal ready to
support my community once again
developer
portal is just the tool a mechanism to
interact with your
application developers um so we highly
recommend you utilize something like
that
we've seen a lot of success in having a
developer portal be that mechanism be
that tool
for your developers what does your
developer onboarding process look like
once again make it simple make it
automated
if it makes sense for your business the
most common example we see here
for a developer onboarding process it's
very much like how when you register for
you know like an online store right um
you know provide me with your email
maybe some basic information
i will shoot you an automated email
confirmation you just you just to
confirm it's a real email address
and once that's done you know bam the
registration process is
is is done uh you can log in and start
reading documentation and potentially
even making some
api calls uh you know if you can get to
that kind of model that's
you know a really good model to kind of
get to just because it's very easy it's
very quick
within a matter of you know seconds
really i can um
start reading up on on api documentation
and getting access to start playing
around with your apis
that kind of ties a little bit into the
the fifth point here which is how
quickly uh can developers obtain an api
key
uh as well where will developers get
answers when they encounter issues so
this is the whole support uh ongoing
support and maintenance that we talked
about earlier
uh and then finally you know what uh
kpis will i track to kind of determine
the um what you what success looks like
so this is more of a kind of an internal
thing but just kind of touch a little
bit about kpis
and once again there's a lot of good
documentation on kpis that are out there
on our apogee website so i encourage you
to look there but when we talk about
kpis here we're talking about things
like
you know the number of active developers
right
not the number of developers the number
of active developers who are
you know consistently using your apis uh
you know the number of useful apis you
know a lot of times we see
our customers think if they have 900
apis that shows a successful api program
we disagree we think having it's not
about the number of apis but it's about
do you have a core set of apis that can
pertain to
a lot of different api products a lot of
different applications
that can be easily reused for a lot of
you know various
you know business cases and use cases
and things like that that is more useful
than
just the sheer number of apis um and
then also of course the speed of
onboarding
traffic growth direct revenue there's a
lot of different ways of kind of
measuring the kpis but
that's kind of one thing you want to
keep in mind is what are the kpis for
your api program
and how does that tie back into the uh
this whole concept of a
user-centric approach so once again i
mean these are just kind of questions to
consider
that you want to ask yourself uh you
know there are a lot of different ways
that you can approach it
but as long as you can approach it once
again from this outside in model that is
something that we
you know the purpose of this webcast is
really kind of to stress that
you know in in particular so all right
so that is
just sort of the high-level overview of
uh what we wanted to talk about when it
comes to this whole kind of
user-centric uh application
consumer-centric approach
to to apis once again i've only touched
upon it at a very very high level i mean
i hope
what you've taken away from this is sort
of how we think of
a you know outside in type approach you
know what what are some of the key
things that we
think are very very important we've only
really touched a little bit uh
at a very high level kind of what our
other customers have done
but you can hopefully have seen the
common trends of at least the approach
that they took
you know when it comes to things like
restful api design when it comes to
things like utilizing developer portal
and just even in terms of the mentality
and how they kind of
switch when it comes to api design
shifting the mentality from an outside
in model to an uh
i'm sorry from an inside out model to an
outside in model
so with that i can kind of see that we
already have a couple
questions already so i'm going to do my
best to get through all of them
if i don't get a chance to get through
all the questions
i definitely will answer them either
offline either after the session is done
or kind of within the chat itself
so if i don't get to your question i do
apologize in advance but i will get to
as many of these
as i can all right uh
first question that i can see here uh
can you elaborate on the restful
approach and how it ties to the whole
outside in
model yeah so um so restful approach uh
you know what i kind of what i was
talking about you know
in the middle of this uh this webcast is
this whole concept of
you know how self-explanatory are the
apis so if
you those who are not familiar i mean
the whole concept of a restful approach
is really
uh things like um you know they have a
certain way of doing like naming
conventions and
and things like that and really that's
kind of what we wanted to emphasize
right i'm
from an api i'll start with naming
convention are the apis
named in such a way where i can very
easily understand what the api can do
so this whole concept of you know like
the whole post and put and delete and
and
you know the verbs and and all that i
mean really the whole a restful approach
is really to
to get to that model where there is a
kind of a universal common understanding
of what an api can do just kind of
based off the name alone so that that's
kind of what i mean by
you know ease of use for the api kind of
following a restful approach
all right other question what do you
mean when you talk about api products uh
yeah so just to kind of reiterate you
know when i talk about api products once
again this is about the the bundling of
the apis
i'm using that whole lego analogy that i
kind of talked about earlier
api products uh and i mentioned this
before it is is really a
core part of how apogee as a platform is
built
you know we uh lean heavily into this
whole concept of api products because we
the way that we see it is that if you
can you know there's one thing to have
an api catalog
but api products is just another
mechanism of you know if you take a
productization approach or a way of
thinking
of of your apis and really you're
starting to think about
packaging those apis to maybe when they
get even to a monetization type model
where you're charging
uh your consumers uh you know per api
call and really the concept behind that
is you know you want to start thinking
of apis as
i have a lot of useful data there are
people
internal external within our company
that
wants to have access to that data
because they can use that data in a lot
of cool ways with their applications
how do i expose that data out in apis
and if you can think about it from a
product model like as if you're trying
to sell those apis and there's some sort
of like monetary
uh return you're gonna get for those
apis that really is putting you in the
right mindset
of you know how you want to think about
when you're exposing out your apis right
if you're thinking from that point per
perspective of i have useful data but
how do i roll it out in such a way where
people want to pay money to use that
then that's
definitely kind of the the first step
into
into a model that you want to get into
that kind of leads to a successful api
program
so so long story short you know that's
that's what we talked about um
api products once again how it
correlates as you are thinking in terms
of
as an app developer i really want to get
access to that cool data that you have
in your back end
you know how would i want to make those
calls as an app developer you know
putting yourself in that
in their shoes uh next
question when it comes to the developer
portal should i start off big or can it
be iterated over time
great question personally what i've seen
is the iteration approach and that is
sort of the approach that i would
recommend
you're not going to get your developer
portal perfect and this goes the same
with apis themselves as well
you're not going to get it right on the
first try right there's going to be
feedback that you're going to get
what you want to avoid probably more
most importantly is you don't want to
spend so much time
trying to create the perfect developer
portal with the perfect registration
process that
you you elongate kind of your your time
to market
uh you know you want to roll something
out there very quick it may not have all
the bells and whistles for example like
developer portal it may not have a
blog or a forum capability to get you
know
right from the start but you want to
roll it out with your apis and you want
to roll them out quickly because you
want to start gathering that feedback
as quickly as possible so in this case i
definitely would recommend that as long
as you kind of get a
in my opinion as long as you can kind of
get a you know very easy to
uh use a kind of registration process
you know maybe some look and feel tweaks
uh and some good documentation up and
running start with the basics start from
there and
kind of iterate over time uh is the
definitely the way that i would go
uh you know one thing that uh you know
ideally you would want to avoid is kind
of rolling out the apis and some sort of
mechanism
you know god forbid it being some sort
of like you know 300 page api
you know document or something like that
that you have to email over to all your
your app uh your app developers uh you
know
the quick more quickly can roll out
developer portal uh the better
in my mind but that was a great question
all right uh let's see you mentioned
capturing feedback from consumers uh
what are some examples of how that can
be done
once again another great question i'm
gonna go back to developer portal here
a lot of times when it comes to feedback
uh you know it could be done through
forms
if you have uh this this idea of
implementing a form
that could be one mechanism um you know
on the developer portal itself there
could be a feedback link
we talked about the role of the api
evangelist or maybe a product owner or
someone who can you know maybe
proactively reach out to application
developers and and kind of get feedback
there
the the importance here is you know not
only do you want to capture feedback and
there's a lot of different ways as i
just described of doing that
but you want to make sure that there is
a process that you build into your
api program and your you know software
delivery life cycle
of how do we take that feedback and
incorporate it into the next iteration
of the api
i think that's the trick here i think
there's a lot of times when people go
down this approach
they think about how to capture the
feedback but they don't really think
about how to
act upon it right so when you're
starting to think about
um you know things like for example we
promote uh like an agile
type you know methodology when it comes
to api development
the reason we promote that is because
you know with with something like agile
and iterative approach
development you can very quickly kind of
turn on a dime and implement
uh you know new feature requests or you
know new feedback you're getting
you know much more quickly than if you
were to do something like in a waterfall
type
type delivery model so it's sort of all
related to that you just want to make
sure that there's a
good mechanism of getting that feedback
back to your your product owners and
your api developers just so that they
can act upon it
that's another great question as well
uh so given the amount of time we have
left uh this is probably the last
question i'll answer
live uh and then we will kind of maybe
jump into answering the rest of the
questions via chat
let's see it's the developer portal for
external users only okay that's a great
question
in my mind and this is what i tell my
customers well
you your developer portal should not
differentiate between internal and
external
and what i mean by that is and this this
kind of goes into the whole philosophy
of your api design as well you know you
don't want to design an api for
oh these apis are for external consumers
and i'm going to design
my internal apis differently you know
from the end of the day you want to look
at your api
consumers as sort of one entity because
at the end of the day
everyone whether they be internal or
external application developers within
your organization
wants apis that are easy to use they
want to get access to those apis
in a quick and efficient manner so you
should always approach it
and always try to strive to make your
apis
as easy to consume as possible
regardless of if there are you know an
external partner a person working
building an application in their garage
or the person just sitting on the
opposite side of the building
right uh you know you have much more
flexibility of course if there are
internal applications because maybe
those application developers already
understand the back-end
services and and what that you know
pertains but you don't want to go down
the path of building kind of
two different versions of the same api
one for internal one for external
if you have the option of building one
api that both parties can use
you know it from a maintainability it's
a lot easier but also just
uh in terms of happy app developers um
you know once again putting you
yourself in the shoes of what can i do
to make their lives a lot easier
so that they can go build their
applications much quicker that is sort
of the approach you want to take so
developer portal falls in that same line
as well to kind of directly answer your
question
when you're building on a developer
portal a lot of times we we tell our
customers that they should build one
developer portal
now what the person can see in that
developer portal in terms of like what
avail
apis are available to them that's where
something like role-based access control
will come in
as an external person using the
developer portal you know i may not see
all the apis that an internal user would
see
but it should still be one portal you
you i
ideally you won't want you won't want to
get into a scenario where you have to
maintain and upkeep two separate
developer portals just from a
cost and operations uh perspective
all right so with that uh i think that
is a wrap for the webcast so once again
thank you so much for for kind of
spending the time
today with me to kind of go over this
topic once again you know it's something
that
we see a lot with our customers it's
sort of the ongoing message that we
promote a lot with our
uh customer base so i really hope that
you know you found this useful
i hope that there is um you know some of
the questions we brought up you know
some of the topics that we talked about
will get you kind of thinking about you
know where you're at with your api
program and more importantly kind of how
do you want to get to that
ideal state of having this whole you
know user-centric approach to your apis
and once again if there are you know any
questions you have definitely reach out
uh you know we have a very robust kind
of community to kind of answer your
questions
once again i mentioned before we have a
very uh
great and robust documentation site for
apogee that not only goes through all
the apogee capabilities but also
even concepts like restful api design
versioning and all these different
things developer portal for example
um so i highly recommend you guys uh
take a look at that um
if if you know that interests you so so
that's a wrap on the webcast once again
thanks again and i hope you guys have a
great day
you